Awkward silence, it's a...
Hi, welcome to DNews, I'm Ross Everett.
Silences.
They can be awkward.
You know that moment where you say something
in a group of your friends and it's met with
a deafening...
That moment that makes you want to grab someone
and shake them saying "I TAKE IT BACK!
WHATEVER I DID TO MAKE YOU HATE ME I JUST
WANT TO UNDO IT!
COME BACK TO ME.
And while they feel like they last eons, turns
out the amount of time it takes to make a
silence awkward is just four seconds...
Of course on an Internet video four seconds
seems even longer.
Case and point: skippable pre-roll ads.
My beard grows in by the time the skip button
shows up.
?
But what exactly happens in those four seconds
that makes us willing to be anywhere else?
Well, a social experiment, or as Facebook
calls it: a new feature, was conducted at
the University of Groningen in the Netherlands,
that showed the importance of conversational
flow.
When a conversation is going strong, or riffing
as I like to call it, we experience positive
emotions, social validation, and a sense of
belonging.
So it only makes sense that when it's brought
to a screeching halt, or stiffing as I call
it, we're flooded by feelings of rejection
and ostracism.
They found this out by having a group of sixty
undergrads watch one of two six-minute videos
of a conversation.
In both videos one person makes a controversial
remark.
In one of the videos, the conversation continues
smoothly and moves onto a different topic.
But in the other video, eeeeerp- the conversation
stops.
For four seconds of silence, after which the
conversation continues.
And while the conversation continues the exact
same way in both videos, the silence in between
made all the difference.
It disrupted the flow enough to make those
that watched the video with the pause feel
"more rejection, more negative emotions, and
less positive emotions" which seems a little
redundant but I wanna give you all the facts.
You never disrupt the flow.
Unless, of course, you're aiming to create
one of those silences that's, well... awkward.
So, what do you guys do during an awkward
silence?
Let me know in the comments down below.
And, hey, if you're all into trending topics
but don't know all the little specifics about
what's going on, head on over to the new TestTube
show and subscribe so you can get that show
in your sub box the same way you're getting
DNews now.
I'm Ross Everett...
1..2..3..4..